プルー
肇社長ですというわけでカラーウォールを5万部を買ってしまったんですけどもこちら
82万円分なんでしょさすがに動画1本1ねポスターが悪いっていうことでもう1でた
痩せてください結婚ないからボールあるとできることが無限大だと思うんですけどそこ
は行って日本です
れて来てこのクールさ
ブーブー移動してその部屋をもう末期ちっなアーチ以降だったああっさててくれ
仕切りは j さあされてると思うんでそれを2円仕掛けて一発でもう終わっと見て
下書きがいるんだ時に集めてどう反応するっていうと思って早速作っていきましょう
ハイテクでまず仕掛けていくとこはこちらブーブー
洗面所でございますこんな下のサイズ感だったため余裕で max まで行くと思うん
で早速おいていきましょうを止めていきましょう
ダンボールで兵を作ってるんでこれからも何しかないとみた
[音楽]
すまっやばいやばいを持ってねこれなんかが強いんですかねこれなんだか面白いできる
しかないな
me
けどちょっとサックのラインが限界まで達しましたこれ以上入るとあふれるんで柵の高
さを上げます
[音楽]
pon
ああああああああ
[音楽]
サーモの国があるでそうやってふたを閉めるかでございますこれくらいだしてまーすと
か常に流れてくるでしょう読みね
いやーよかったですねいい形で来てるんだよ
[音楽]
多分一番やなぁと思っては一番やってみましょうヘッドジョーズよはい
のパティを待っていうかありませんこれらはいらっしゃるからござい
ごぞ
cap
car
5対象品の西賀ターン果たしたですね
この暖房のできました来週よ不可能などラインということ俺が証明してやろう
フカボス
[音楽]
九里波形
ええええええ
ああああああ
結構めいいっぱい入れましたけどめっちゃきつい
はいちょっと違うと中を見てみましょうか
カメラで行った勝手なんだけどこんな感じですね5点蔵キーまで力だと思います二つ目
ねいきましょうはい杖でのかそれはここ
トイレでございますやそいで攻めで結束たまでパンパンになると思うんで早速おいて
いきましょう
[音楽]
ブーバーね
よってっていきましょうはい
たーーーーます
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
[音楽]
はいとりあえず無事2つの部屋をカラーボール行ったりすることができました
めっちゃ期2なかったですよ
やっぱの部屋兄何かモノを言えば出るって言うのはとっても難しいことだなって思い
ました
アイジャグこの部屋とこの部屋がカラーボールでいっぱいになっておりますまあ
ターゲットなんですけどもうケース決めに修行と思ってまして
あいつリアクションがワンパターン何かあったらこう
じゃないかちょっと超えた目でいうと8位みたいなところがあるんで多分会津の
リアクション国当てれるんですよ多分計9ネクソンはきっと
かいや多いかガチャ頃らー
達が入った分ここらへんだと思いますぜひ彼のリアクションにも注目してみてください
とだけでに限度けしかけていきましょうでは
ああああああ
にすぐですもう
ええええええ
ないですか4さっき十分以上あったっけといるめっちゃカスタマイズしたいです
粕川イスト1回目で見慣れないけど移住が組
いけるトイレ行こうとしてパターンです
それ以降
[音楽]
ああああああああああっこれはヤバいでしょマイターかけるっていう
いえ公開はいと呼びたとえで開けるとカラーボールが心臓より佐賀市が落ちてくるの宿
でした
可愛いぞもうこれか道府県の名産
はーい
me
もうそうそう1回五輪がん
剛王
ええええええ
蟷螂龍刀流
noooooo
おおおおおお
ん
ni
さぁさぁでーもー
[音楽]
ブービーへ
あっはっはー
ん
うわぁ no ワールドこれ
部屋を破っだろう
nbf わっはっは
ran が影響終わってるわ